Short is more difficult and I think we
have to be recognized.
Uh,
we're in for a,
a long,
difficult,
a top problem.
Uh,
things have not even reached the bottom.
One of the problems that we face is not
only if we lost confidence in our
financial institutions,
we've lost confidence in votes who are
supposed to be managing our economy.
Uh,
I can tell you for a fact,
you know,
they were going around your friends
things,
a g eight,
seven meetings and saying last May
saying we've turned the corner,
you know,
things are turning up.
Things are going well.
I'm clearly,
uh,
they were either doing a sales job or
they didn't understand,
but in either case,
why should anybody listen to these guys
again,
they've been so consistently wrong.
So,
uh,
the,
um,
there is this crisis of confidence,
the problems we're going to get worse.
Uh,
we're only about halfway through the
fall and the housing prices,
housing prices go down more,
more,
more foreclosures will occur halfway
through,
assuming we don't overshoot that is to
say when you have a bubble,
when the bubble breaks,
you don't typically go back to the
normal level.
You go further down and then you bounce
back up.
So things may be even worse than what I
just suggested.
If there is overshooting.
Secondly,
states and localities are facing serious
problems.
Revenues are plummeting here in New York
City.
New York state depends very heavily on
revenues from the financial sector.
It's plummeting,
uh,
but states and localities depends have,
I wouldn't call it a balanced budget
framework.
When revenues go down,
they have to cut back expenditures.
And as they cut back expenditures,
the economy goes further down.
AIESEC several months ago that the first
agenda in stimulus ought to be to make
up for the shortfall in this state and
local revenues.
Because if you don't,
you're going to have a downward pressure
on the economy,
cut back of services to the poor,
a cutback of investments that would be
the basis of longterm economic growth.
But the Bush administration decided to
give a tax cut.
They think the tax cut a is a solution
to every problem.
The tax cuts were part of the problem.
The problem of America is not that we
consume too little with the savings rate
of zero.
How could anybody say that?
Yet that was the solution that the Bush
administration put forward.
So,
um,
uh,
the future cutbacks in state and local
expenditures are going to depress the
economy,
uh,
as the banking sector faces problems,
they're going to be more reluctant to
lend.
And as people see their houses price go
down,
they're going to be more reluctant to
borrow.
Uh,
the lack of transparency means that even
banks won't lend to each other.
So if there's a bank with money,
it's not going to be willing to lend to
a bank with the problem because it
doesn't know what the risk that it faces
are.
So,
uh,
I think we're good.
Mike say it only in the first half of
this game,
and,
uh,
I,
I would expect that the problems to
continue to unfold,
I think we're in a very difficult
position because the,
uh,
people that we turn to
traditionally have been the financial
markets and there are two reasons not to
trust them at this point.
First,
they've shown an enormous in competence.
Why should we trust these people who got
us into the mess to get us out of it?
Their judgments,
their understanding of the economy is
very,
very limited.
They understand how to make money in
good times,
how to protect themselves at the expense
of their investors.
They understand that,
but we're talking about a systemic and
economic why phenomena and they've
clearly demonstrated a lack of
competence in that area.
And secondly,
they have a vested interest.
Um,
you know,
they,
they want to protect their own future
and they're willing to let the economy
go down.
Um,
you know,
repeatedly a secretary treasurer try to
get Wall Street to come together and
say,
look,
it looks help Lehmann brothers.
They said,
no,
we'd rather see the economy go down.
Then to put our balance sheet at risk,
so their interests are clearly
divergent.
Take Fatty Mac and Fannie Mae.
When we did the first bailout didn't
work.
When did the first bail out?
Right after that they found Fannie Mae a
issue,
a dividend payment,
putting the taxpayer even more at risk.
They were taking money out as the
government was saying,
we'll put money in.
I mean,
it's unconscionable.
So there's a clear divergence of
interest so we can't turn to them.
We can't turn to political leaders that
are dependent on money from the
lobbyists from Wall Street,
which is particularly true with the
Republican Party in,
in this coming election.
So I think on unfortunately,
that I think we have to turn to
academics,
people who've studied the matter that
have a,
don't have a vested interest other than
the best interest of making sure our
economy functions well and our jobs are
protected.
Uh,
you know,
and,
and our families,
our houses don't go down,
but it's that broader national interest
that I think,
uh,
we really have to be protecting.
And I don't think we can turn to one
street to get the answer.